- Now I know you promised Nance
that you would keep us safe.
So keep us safe.
(booms)
(sighs)
(bangs)
- Hey, dickheads.
How come the only one helping
me out is this random girl?
We lose light in 40 minutes, let's go.
Let's go I said.
- [Dustin] All right, asshole!
God.
- Stupid.
- If a coach calls a play in the game
bottom line you execute it, all right?
- Okay first of all this
isn't some stupid sports game
and second, we're not even in the game
we're on the bench.
- Right, so my point is ...
Right, yeah, we're on the bench
so there's nothing we can do.
- Maybe if we set this on fire.
- No yeah, that's a no.
- The Mind Flayer would
call away his army.
- They'd all come to stop us.
- Hey.
- Then we circle
back to the exit.
- Guys.
- By the time they realize
we're gone--
- El would
be at the gate.
- Hey.
Hey, hey, hey.
(clapping)
It's not happening.
- But--
- No, no, no, no, no,
no buts, I promised I'd
keep you shitheads safe
and that's exactly what I plan on doing.
We're staying here on the bench
and we're waiting for the starting team
to do their job, does
everybody understand that?
- This isn't a stupid sports game!
- I said does everybody understand that?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey,
I don't think so.
Any of you little shits die down here
I'm getting the blame.
Got it, dipshit?
- Didn't you hear our code red?
- Yeah, and I couldn't understand
half of what you were saying.
- God damn low battery!
- How many times do I have to tell you
with the low battery!?
- [Dustin] You have to admit
as just as a feat of engineering
alone this is impressive.
- What are you talking about?
It's a total fire hazard,
there's no stairs,
there's no exit, there's just an elevator
that drops you half way to hell.
I may be a pretty shitty boyfriend but ...
Turns out I'm actually a
pretty damn good babysitter.
- You're an idiot Steve Harrington.
No, Steve!
(booms)
- What is, what the?
- You need to get outta here.
- What is all this?
- Listen to me, I'm not asking you,
I'm telling you--
- What is that smell--
- Get out of here!
- Is that gasoline!?
(gun clicks)
- Steve, get out.
- Wait, wait, what!?
- It's here.
- Wait what?
- [Jonathan] Here.
- Where is it?
- Where is what, whoa!
Easy with that!
- Where is it?
- I don't know, I don't see it.
- Where's what!?
Whoa, will someone explain to me
what the hell is going--
(crashes)
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh!
(sinister music)
(door slams)
Jesus, Jesus, what the hell was that?
What the hell was that!?
- [Both] Shut up!
- [Steve] What is that?
- [Group] Morse code.
- [Hopper] H-E-R-E.
- His army.
- What do you mean?
Whoa, slow down, slow down.
- It believes it's the master race.
- Like the, like the Germans.
- The Nazis?
- Yeah yeah, yeah the Nazis.
- Russian?
(speaking in Pig Latin)
- Ho-ho-ho-ho!
- Holy shit!
- That was Pig Latin, dingus.
- Idiot.
You think the Russians know about?
- They could.
- So it's connected?
- Maybe.
- How?
- I don't know, but it's possible.
- [Robin] I'm sorry is
there something you two
would like to share with the class?
(winds growling)
- The gate.
- I'm sorry, who are you?
- I'm Robin, I work with Steve.
- She cracked the top secret code.
- Yeah which is how we found out
about the Russians in the first place.
- Russians, but what Russians?
- The Russians!
- What happened to that car?
- El has super powers.
- [Robin] I'm sorry?
- Super powers, she
threw it with her mind.
Come on, catch up.
So I'll be over around, say like eight?
- Are you crazy?
My mom would not allow
that.
- I'll climb through
your window, she won't
even know I'm there.
I'm stealthy, like a ninja.
(booms)
(crashes)
(thumps)
(grunts)
Holy shit.
(growling)
(scraping)
(whacks)
(monster screams)
You gotta be slow.
Gotta be stealthy, like a ninja.
(suspenseful music)
(ticking)
(intense suspenseful music)
(chair squeaks)
(bangs)
What'd I tell you?
Ninja.
- Did you not hear the
part about the massive gun?
- Yes, Dustin, I did.
And that's why I would be sneaking.
- Well please, tell me
this, and be honest.
Have you ever actually won a fight?
- Their family is a
disgrace to the entire--
(grunts)
(punches)
(mumbling)
- Or what?
Or what?
You gonna fight me now too, huh!?
- No one tells me what to do.
(smacking)
(grunts)
(yelling)
(cheering)
(screaming)
(smacks)
(swishing)
(grunting)
(thuds)
(smacks)
(intense swelling music)
(whacks)
(grunts)
(smashes)
(thuds)
(panting)
- Dude, you did it!
You won a fight!